"
PRESIDENT BIDEN INSISTING THE
WAY HE GOT OUT OF AFGHANISTAN
WAS AN EXTRAORDINARY SUCCESS.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DISAGREE.
HIS NUMBERS NOSE DIVING AFTER
THE CHAOTIC EXIT.
A NEW NATIONAL POLL OUT SAYING
BIDEN'S AWFUL AUGUST.
APPROVAL SINKS.
LARGE MAJORITY CALL AFGHAN WAR A
FAILURE.
43% OF AMERICAN AS PROVE OF THE
JOB HE'S DOING.
THE LOWEST IN THAT POLL SINCE
BIDEN TOOK OFFICE.
AS THE PRESIDENT LOOKS TO PUSH
PAST AFGHANISTAN, THE MEDIA IS
IGNORING A BIG DEVELOPMENT.
THE MAJOR NETWORKS LARGELY
AVOIDING BIDEN'S PHONE CALL WITH
THEN AFGHAN PRESIDENT GHANI
WHERE PRESIDENT BIDEN REPORTED
THE AFGHAN LEAD TORE SAY THE
TALIBAN WASN'T WINNING.
ALL RIGHT, GUYS.
IT'S FRIDAY.
WE HAVE DARK TOPICS TO DISCUSS.
JOEY, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
THE PRESIDENT CALLING THIS AN
EXTRAORDINARY SUCCESS.
>> IT'S ABOUT BLAMING BIDEN FOR
THE CRISIS.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT.
IT'S ABOUT BEING A LEADER.
STRONG LEADERS MAKE BAD
DECISIONS.
EVERY LEADER MAKES A BAD
DECISION BUT THEY LEAD THROUGH
IT.
WHEN AS A LEADER PRESIDENT BIDEN
COWERS.
HE SAYS THE BUCK STOPS WITH ME.
YOU WELL YOUR WAY INTO A VICTORY
SPEECH.
YOU'VE JUST DON'T SHOW THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT YOU
UNDERSTAND THE GRAVITY THAT IS
FELT IN THIS HOUSE THAT WE CALL
AMERICA.
IT'S NOT JUST THE FACT THAT WE
PULLED OUT OF AFGHANISTAN.
IT'S NOT THE FACT THAT WE HAVE A
20-YEAR WAR.
IT'S THE POSTURE.
A MARINE GENERAL SAID THE
TALIBAN ARE OUR PARTNERS.
YOU HAVE ABOUT 22 MILLION
VETERANS THAT GO WOW.
WERE WE BETRAYED?
WHAT HAPPENED HERE?
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THE TONE
AND TENOR OF THE MEN AND WOMEN
THAT FOUGHT THIS WAR IN ORDER TO
END IT.
HE DOESN'T.
>> ONE THING THAT MOST
POLITICSES DO UNDERSTAND IS POLL
NUMBERS, A LOT OF BAD ONES FOR
THE PRESIDENT ON A NUMBER OF
ISSUES.
WE DID SEE HIS NUMBERS COMING
DOWN BEFORE THIS CHAOTIC
WITHDRAWAL AND THE LOSS OF 13
SERVICE MEMBERS AND OTHERS
CRITICALLY WOUNDED.
>> YEAH, WHAT HAPPENS IS, YOU
HAVE A SITUATION WHERE THE MEDIA
HAS HIS BACK.
WHETHER IT'S COVID, THE BORDER,
INFLATION, THE MEDIA HAS NOT
REPORTED THE STORIES.
IN AFGHANISTAN, THE MEDIA HAD TO
REPORT THE STORY.
SO AS THEY REPORT IT, THEY SEE
IT'S AN UTTER FAILURE.
13 SERVICE MEMBERS DIED,
BILLIONS LEFT IN OUR EQUIPMENT.
TO JOEY'S POINT, WE LOOK AT
LEADERSHIP.
YOU WANT LEADERS TO CHANGE
COURSE WITH THE FACTS ON THE
GROUND.
SO IF YOU'RE GETTING FROM THE
AFGHAN PRESIDENT THAT YOU HAVE
ALMOST 15,000 INTERNATIONAL
TERRORISTS COMING IN TO THE
COUNTRY, THE TALIBAN IS SURGING,
YOU EXPECT THE CHANGE TO CHANGE
COURSE.
KEEP BAGRAM.
BRING IN MORE TROOPS TO GET
AMERICANS OUT.
THAT'S THE WAY TO APPROACH IT.
EVEN DONALD TRUMP, HE WANTED TO
GET OUT OF AFGHANISTAN AT THE
END OF 2020.
BECAUSE OF THE FACTS ON THE
GROUND, HE KEPT PUSHING THE DATE
BACK BECAUSE HE WAS A LEADER
LOOKING AT FACTS, NOT AS
PERCEPTION AS JOE BIDEN WANTED
TO DO TO SENT A PERCEPTION OF
THE WORLD.
>> THERE'S BEEN A CONVERSATION
THE LAST COUPLE WEEKS WHETHER
SEEING HOW TERRIBLY THE THINGS
WERE GOING THE PRESIDENT WOULD
CHANGE COURSE.
BUT REPORTING FROM INSIDE THE
ADMINISTRATION SAYS HE SURROUNDS
HIMSELF WITH PEOPLE THAT HAVE
DIFFERING VIEWPOINTS TO
CHALLENGE HIM BUT IT'S HARD TO
CHANGE HIS MIND ONCE HE DECIDED
THIS IS THE COURSE.
>> IT'S ONE OF THE ADVANTAGES OF
GETTING SOMEONE IN OFFICE THAT
YOU'VE KNOWN FOR 50 YEARS.
THEY'RE CONSISTENT.
JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN STUBBORN ON
FOREIGN POLICY SINCE HE ENTERED
PROFESSIONAL D.C. PUBLIC LIFE.
SO IT ISN'T SURPRISING.
HE'S SURROUNDED BY VIRTUAL OF
THE FACT THAT SO MANY MEMBERS OF
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION WERE --
PLAYED AN INTEGRAL ROLE IN
CONTINUING THIS FIGHT IN
AFGHANISTAN AND FELT PASSIONATE
LIT ABOUT THAT.
WORKED WITH AFGHANS THAT HELPED
US AS TRANSLATORS AND HAS BEEN
QUITE OUTSPOKEN WHETHER THEY
DELETED THE TWEETS THEY PUT UP
OR INSTAGRAM POSTS.
THERE'S MEMBERS OF THE STATE
DEPARTMENT, DOD THAT EXPRESSED
DISPLEASURE.
TO JOEY'S POINT, THERE'S
SOMETHING INTERESTING IN THE
POLLING.
THERE'S THAT DICHOTOMY THAT TOO
MANY POLITICIANS MISS.
AMERICANS ARE SMART ENOUGH TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THESE ISSUES ARE.
WHILE HE'S SUNK HIM TO LOW 40s,
YOU STILL HAVE 65 TO 70% OF
AMERICANS THAT THIS THIS IS THE
RIGHT CALL.
>> THAT ARE SMART ENOUGH TO KNOW
THIS --
>> AND HOW HE DID IT.
THAT'S WHY HE'S GETTING
CRITICISM FROM DEMOCRATS AND
INDEPENDENTS SAYING YEAH, WE'RE
FOR THIS.
20 YEARS IS ENOUGH OF THIS.
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHO IS LEFT
BEHIND.
LET'S TALK ABOUT HOW QUICKLY
THIS HAPPENED.
WE DID NEED TO BE OUT BY
SEPTEMBER 11th.
IT'S AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT DAY
IN AMERICAN HISTORY BUT NOT THE
BE ALL AND END ALL OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE SCARED OF A NEW TERROR
ATTACK OR TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE THAT WERE PROMISED A NEW
LIFE HERE IN AMERICA FOR HELPING
US.
>> THE WAY YOU TALK ABOUT THAT,
THAT GETS THE HEADLINE WITH ABC
AND "WASHINGTON POST," THEIR
POLL OUT TODAY.
IT DOESN'T HAVE A TON OF GREAT
NEWS FOR THE PRESIDENT.
SO GOOD MORNING AMERICA SPENT 30
SECONDS ON THEIR POLL.
THE "WASHINGTON POST"'S
HEADLINE.
MOST PEOPLE ARE READY TO GO.
THAT'S HOW THEY'RE FRAMING THE
NEGATIVE NUMBERS.
>> SO THE POLLS TO YOUR POINT --
THE POLLS ARE A CALL TO ACTION
FOR THE MEDIA THAT THEY HAVE TO
JUMP IN AND HELP JOE BIDEN.
THEY'RE GOING TO IGNORE THE
STORIES THAT NEED TO BE COVERED.
LIKE DON LEMON AND CHRIS HAYES,
THEY'RE GOING TO TRY TO REWRITE
HISTORY NOW.
THESE GRIFTERS PAWNED OFF THIS
DEFECTIVE HUMAN H BOMB TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
MORE AROUND MORE -- WE WANT TO
GIVE HIM BACK.
THEY ACTIVELY AND SOMETIMES
UNETHICALLY GOT JOE BIDEN
ELECTED.
REMEMBER THE HUNTER BIDEN LAB
TOP AND THE 50 SENIOR
INTELLIGENCE OFFICERS SAID IT
WAS RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION?
DO THEY STILL HAVE JOBS?
MAYBE THEIR PLAYERS OUGHT TO
RETHINK THAT.
THIS COUNTRY RIGHT NOW LOOKS
LIKE AN EXPLODING SEPTIC TANK.
THESE MEDIA CON ARTISTS, THIS IS
WHAT THEY SAID WOULD HAPPEN
UNDER SECOND TERM FOR PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
IT GOES TO THE POINT AND I SAY
THIS OVER AND OVER AGAIN, POLICY
IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
PERSONALITY.
A PERSON WITH FLAWS PERSONALITY
HAS A BIGGER IMPACT ON THE
NATION.
JESSICA, YOU SAID JOE BIDEN WAS
CONSISTENT.
I'D SAY CONSISTENTLY TERRIBLE
WHEN IT COMES TO FOREIGN POLICY.
HE WAS AGAINST THE RAID THAT
TOOK OUT OSAMA BIN LADEN.
HE STANDS UP OVER AND OVER AGAIN
AND LIES TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SO PLEASE DO NOT SPIT IN OUR
FACE AND TELL US IT'S RAINING.
WE KNOW BETTER.
>> THE SURGE WAS THE SINGLE MOST
EFFECTIVE THING WE DID IN THE
IRAQ WAR.
WE DID IT IN 2009, 10, 11.
HE WAS VICE PRESIDENT FOR EIGHT
YEARS OF THIS WAR AND YOU WANT
TO STAND THEM AND TELL ME YOU
INHERIT IT?
PROBABLY THE ONLY PRESIDENT THAT
DIDN'T INHERIT THIS WAR BECAUSE
YOU WERE IN CHARGE OF'S FOR
EIGHT YEARS OF IT.
YOU CAN ARGUE GEORGE W. BUSH GOT
A RAW DEAL FROM HIS PREDECESSOR
THAT ADD A CHANCE TO KILL BIN
LADEN MULTIPLE TIMES.
>> WE TALKED ABOUT THIS BEFORE
THE SHOW.
I SUPPORTED THE WITHDRAW.
I SUPPORTED IT WITH TRUMP.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
BRINGING EVERY LAST TROOP HOME
OR COULD WE HAVE SOME PRESENCE
IN BAGRAM, OFFERED AIR SUPPORT
TO THE TROOPS TO PUSH BACK THE
TALIBAN.
WE NEED JOEY JONES GUYS ON THE
GROUND, BUT COULD HAVE HAD A
PRESENCE TO HELP SECURE
AFGHANISTAN AND MAKE SURE THE
TALIBAN DOESN'T TAKE OVER.
>> THAT'S BEEN THE MISSION SINCE
2014.
IT WAS A COUNTER TERRORISM
OPERATION.
WE HAVE TO CIA LISTENING POSTS,
NOBODY ON THE GROUND GATHERING
INTELLIGENCE.
>> THAT'S PART OF THE PROBLEM.
>> AND NOW WE HAVE BLOWN OUR
PARTNERSHIPS TO FEED US
INFORMATION.
>> AND BLOWN UP OUR RELATIONSHIP
WITH BRITAIN, GERMANY AND
FRANCE.
>> THESE ARE THE ADULT THERES
THE ROOM.
THESE ARE T